uh the trump family doesn't have a great
track record when it comes to charity
and donations trump often promising
donations which he never gives
we've talked about the trump uh
foundation or whatever it was called
having to stop operating as part of an
agreement based on an investigation into
the fraudulent nature of that well
melania trump is now getting pulled into
it a melania trump event is being
investigated after promising to donate
proceeds to a charity uh oh that doesn't
appear to exist
a charity event set to be hosted by
melania in florida is being investigated
after organizers said a portion of its
proceeds would go to a charity that does
not appear to exist per the new york
times
the organizers have said the high tea
event in april in naples florida will
benefit fostering the future a b best
initiative granting computer science
scholarships to those aging out of the
foster care system tickets are three
grand vip tickets are 50 grand we don't
know what percentage would go to charity
but what's the real problem
the real problem is the new york times
found no charity with the name fostering
the future or be best registered in
florida now you might say well maybe
they're just not registered but in
florida the law requires that
organizations soliciting donations
register so that you know it's a real
charity
consumer services division is currently
investigating whether this event
involves an entity operating in
violation of chapter 496
florida statutes
melania trump
denies that the charity doesn't exist
the new york times of course reported
this initially and uh people following
up
following the launch of her line of nfts
and the auction of a white hat she wore
at the white house she's selling tickets
for this april 9 event in naples
the tulips and topiaries high tea is
pitched as a once in a lifetime
experience an afternoon of sophisticated
elegance set in elaborate lush floral
gardens designed to inspire giving hope
possibility and dreams
um there's no indication of how much
money will be raised
uh and melania says the reporting that
the charity doesn't exist is false she
tweeted dishonest reporting added again
everything has been done lawfully and
all documents are in the works read with
caution typical corrupt media she added
she's working with the bradley impact
fund which calls itself a donor-advised
fund for
conservatives does it exist or not we
don't know but it has real human fund
vibes i don't know how many of you guys
are for you know seinfeld fans but
there's an episode in which the george
costanza character
starts asking for donations to the human
fund which is fake it's just him it's
him it's you know money for people is
the slogan and the money just goes to
george and this is just apparently with
melania the continuing grift upon grift
upon griff that has been the trump
presidency the campaign he ran was a
grift
and then the presidency was a grift
and then the fundraising in order to
overturn it was a grift it's all a grift
and it now involves melania trump and uh
is the charity real or not well it's
certainly not registered with the state
of florida that alone is enough to make
it all against the law they will never
stop unless someone stops them i hope
that you will all join me
tuesday march 1 now just about 10 days
away
for joe biden's state of the union
address this is expected to be one of
the most consequential state of the
union addresses in a long time for a
number of different reasons will joe
biden signal the end of the pandemic
phase of covid what will be going on
with ukraine russia
what will be signaled about the 2022
midterms which themselves will be so
consequential for 2024
major major uh state of the union
address we will be live on youtube
twitch and facebook starting one hour
before the speech i hope you will join
me and stick around today we'll be
taking some of your calls i'll be
reading some of your emails and so much
more to discuss
follow me on twitter at dpakman let me
know what you think about melania's
so-called charity we'll take a quick
break and be right back
one of our sponsors is kamikoto who
creates elegant high-end japanese steel
kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from honshu japan
i'm a huge fan of japanese kitchen
knives i've owned a bunch of different
sets none as nice as my kamikodo knives
made with real japanese steel every
knife comes in a beautiful heavy duty
ash wood box and a lifetime guarantee
you can get them in several different
sets and combinations kamikoto makes it
really easy to figure out which one is
best for you you can also pick up one of
kamikodo's sharpening wet stones which
are designed especially for kamikodo
knives i've had an excellent experience
using kamikodo knives in my kitchen at
home it just feels comfortable in your
hand the mechanics of slicing with high
quality japanese knives like these feel
really really nice and right now
kamikoto is having a huge valentine's
day sale
you get 50 off on top of their other
offers when you go to kamikodo.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below